There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
from February to test for ourselves.
I haven't tried a Hard Candy
product since I was a kid,
but this glitter palette
blew up on TikTok.
This is the Glitteratzi
glitter eye palette
in Glitz N' Cheer.
The glitter is not loose.
It does have some sort of sticky base
that holds it together
and makes it really easy to glide on.
I was honestly blown away
by how pigmented these glitters are.
I used my fingers to apply it to my eyes.
These top two shades do that thing where
depending on what angle your face is at,
the glitter disappears and reappears.
It's so magical and pretty.
I will say that I did get glitter fallout,
so I'd recommend using
another glitter base
to make sure that doesn't happen,
but I had fun playing
around with this palette.
If you're someone who's into glitter,
I highly recommend it.
Fenty Beauty just came out
with the Icon semi-matte
refillable lipstick.
So the case and the actual
lipstick are sold separately,
and then you assemble them together.
I'm not gonna lie, it took
me a minute to figure out,
but I did eventually.
I got the shade The MVP,
which is another universal red from Fenty
that's supposed to look
good on every skin tone.
The shape of the lipstick
was actually inspired
by Rihanna's iconic Cupid's bow,
and I actually found it really easy
to sort of map out my lip line with it,
since I didn't apply any lip liner before.
The pigment is incredible
and totally full coverage.
It's just a very creamy formula
that feels so smooth and
hydrating on the lips.
I can't even believe this is semi-matte.
It's definitely not transfer-proof,
but I was actually really impressed
by how it looked after I kissed my hand.
Clearly so much product came off,
but the lipstick still looked incredible.
It is interesting to see
regular lipstick releases
in the age of mask wearing,
but this formula is excellent.
NARS has a new foundation formula,
the Light Reflecting
Advanced Skincare foundation.
NARS knows how to do
complexion products so well,
and it has a huge hit with this.
I've actually been using
this for weeks now,
and I'm completely in love with it.
The foundation is so
lightweight on the skin.
It feels like you're not
even wearing foundation.
The coverage is on the
light to medium side,
but I definitely think you can build it up
without it getting cakey.
The finish is so nice.
It makes your skin look
really fresh and dewy
without looking oily,
and all of my other products layer
on top of this foundation really well.
KVD Beauty released its Good Apple
lightweight full-coverage concealer.
The name had me so intrigued,
because usually full-coverage products
can get heavy on the skin,
and my under-eyes are so picky
about what concealer they like.
I immediately love this applicator shape.
It picks up a good amount of product,
and the shape makes it easy to apply.
I could tell from testing it
out on the back of my hand
that it actually does
feel way more lightweight
than I expected, but
it covers really well.
I applied it everywhere I
normally apply concealer,
let it all sit for a second,
and then started blending.
This concealer blends like a dream.
It just melts into the skin
without losing any coverage.
I did add a little more
on my under-eye area
just for some extra brightening,
and it layered beautifully,
no problems there,
and then I set it all with the powder,
and I think it still looked really good
while feeling super-light on the face.
The name did not lie.
Colourpop released these adorable
heart-shaped pressed-powder blushes
just in time for Valentine's Day.
They kept selling out,
but I managed to get
this bright coral shade
called 4Ever Yours.
These blushes look
deceptively matte in the pan,
but if you look at my finger swatch,
it's definitely got a
pretty sheen, which I love.
This blush was so unbelievably pigmented.
I tapped my brush off before I applied it,
and it still went on this intensely.
But I went back in with a
clean brush to tone it down,
and it looked so much better.
This blush formula is
really silky and pretty,
plus a little goes a really
long way, so I love this.
Also, I am a sucker for
anything heart-shaped.
Karla Cosmetics is a
totally new brand for me,
and I've been dying to try its
Shadow Potion gel eye shadow.
It's this multichrome gel eye shadow.
I swatched it on my hand first,
and this texture isn't something
I've really tried before.
I just went in with my fingers
and did gentle tapping motions.
It does dry quickly, but not so quickly
that you don't have time to work with it.
It definitely showed up as
more pinky-purple on my eyes
with olive green on the outer corners.
That multichrome shift
depends on the lighting,
so I think it looked more obvious
away from direct sunlight.
Milk Makeup recently
released this Rise mascara.
I actually love their Kush mascara,
so I was really excited to try this,
and then I actually tried it.
This is just so average.
It took me three layers
for it to give my lashes any sort of lift,
and even that effect was subtle.
I've tried drugstore mascaras
that have done a lot more for a lot less.
This is the mini size,
and it was 14 bucks.
I will say I did love the packaging.
This material kind of
feels like a pencil grip,
and I love that.
The actual mascara, not so much.